The cache first, then network strategy
is ideal for our weather app.
It gets the weather forecast on
screen as quickly as possible.
Then, it updates the forecast
once the network
has returned with the latest data.
Using this strategy, we expect
the network response to be the source of
truth, always providing us
with the most up-to-date data.
To implement this strategy,
we need to kick off two
parallel asynchronous requests.
One to the cache, so we can get some
data on screen as quickly as possible,
even though it might be stale.
The second request is made over
the network to get the latest data.
Under normal circumstances,
the cache data will be returned almost
immediately, providing the app with
some recent data that it can use.
Then, when the network request returns,
the app should store the response in
the cache and update the screen with
the latest data it just received.
This also means that even on Wi-Fi
networks or when there's no network
connection at all,
the user still sees data from the cache.